it's not too bad is it okay
yeah if you need me okay just make sure
he's got those white eyes like I do
so do you we're all no it's the when
they use the the foil outside or
whatever you can't keep my eyes open to
save my life
just for three seconds I'm like I can't
yeah
my eyes won't do it
yeah okay we're going all right Glenn
saying spell first last name title Glenn
Simpson
g-l-e-n-s-i-m-p-s-o-n senior director
Community Ambulance okay obviously we're
here to talk about one October which is
tough for all of us who are here I know
it's especially hard for you and your
crew
anything I ask that you don't want to go
back into or relive we don't have to
okay so this is your interview I'm just
asking a question appreciate it all
right
um that night you guys were amongst the
first responder
I don't know you've been called Heroes
you've been called Saints you've been
called angels and you guys showed up to
work to do your job just like any other
night
um what was it like in that moment
yeah you know I think what I think one
of the big unique things of that night
is typically in our world when we when
we train one of the first things that we
we just preach and constantly dwell into
our crew's head is seeing safety we
don't enter unsafe scenes that's not our
job that is not our role that's what law
enforcement is for and it's not until
law enforcement gives the all clear or
some level of it being clear that then
we begin to move crews in and go to work
what was unique that night was we had
been contracted to provide medical
services for for the festival and we we
had a
we had a duty and obligation a want to
to begin responding from within and
that's what we did you know the the
countless stories of just our Personnel
that were assigned to the event those
that work for us that
um you know that night they were there
to enjoy the concert and like
like anybody they had the opportunity to
get out of there and they chose to stay
behind I don't know how you put into
words what
one what that makes you feel like as
somebody who was tasked with leading
this group and and two how you just put
that into words that
you have the opportunity to be
surrounded and work with people that
are
so focused on helping others
you guys
pray In Harm's Way as well
whether you were attending the concert
or whether you were working it
um
first thoughts
you want to run into it even though you
are taught in scene safety it's one of
the first things a First Responders
thought
um
did you go quick or did you guys
hold back for a second kind of get your
bearings to see what was going on did
you have people coming up to you I mean
what was kind of the scene like yeah so
you know
um
like any large scale event that we do we
have Crews that are strategically placed
throughout the venue we're at the point
now in the event where the main Act is
on the stage so naturally that's where
the crowd is the crowd is focused on
that main stage any other activation has
been shut down and so crews are
strategically placed uh one end of the
the venue we have a large medical tent
that that seeing patients you know for
for various things whether that's you
know blisters Cuts I had a little too
much to drink tonight whatever that may
be and so business as usual
me in particular I was helping some
guests of the concert into a cab and so
at the moment just before we heard the
first volley I was putting two guests
into a taxi cab that then would head in
Northbound on the strip for me at that
moment it was me turning around
at that point I was I was I was about
ready to call it a day myself it had
been long weekend the crews were in
place the crews were doing what they
needed to do there was not necessarily a
need for me to be there and my vehicle
was was parked
more or less behind the venue but
walking South and so as I turned around
and began that walk that's when we heard
what was the first volley not realizing
that's what it was and trying to figure
out exactly what was going on I'm
surrounded by you know other Metro
officers and everyone's kind of looking
up looking down looking right looking
left trying to figure out what's going
on and that's when you know law
enforcement began to take cover behind a
wall that separates the the street from
the sidewalk on Las Vegas Boulevard
naturally I I followed suit and took
cover behind that wall that's when you
quickly realized that this wasn't
this wasn't crackling power lines this
wasn't
this wasn't some sort of drive-by this
wasn't any scenario you would you could
fathom this was shots were being fired
in our Direction
and for me the you know again going back
to you know we teach scene safety we
also teach crew safety you know if we're
not if we're not safe or if we get
injured then we're no help to to those
that need our help but on the flip side
there was for me
16 of my co-workers that were inside 16
people that I played a part in assigning
to this event that
I felt
I have a responsibility for when we go
and work these events you know we do
briefings we don't talk about
you know let's let's all make sure that
we get home safe tonight it's not it's
not a normal part of briefing but
there's that underlying
responsibility that you have as a leader
to to make sure that
that we leave the same way that we
arrived and in those moments that became
a very real reality that
this is bad something's happening
there's going to be a lot of people
coming our way really fast and this is
what we
want to say this is what we train for
but this is what we talk about this is
it this is this is the big one
um and so for me it was it never crossed
my mind that I needed to get out of
there what crossed my mind was I need to
find my people
I need to
we need to group together we need to
come up with a plan and we need to get
out there and go to work
little did I know our teams were already
going to work they were grabbing people
they were pulling people underneath the
stage they were they were beginning that
evacuation moment
um I can only imagine what was going
through their mind you know through my
mind you everything from
are my co-workers safe
I probably should try to call my family
real quick I should write just a laundry
list of
what's going on what's happening right
now all the while not knowing where not
knowing where the bullets are coming
from but just constantly hearing bullets
um you know from hearing bullets to the
next thing you do is you can you can
smell burning flesh from people that had
you know either been grazed by a bullet
or been shot by a bullet
you begin journeying through the venue
trying to get to you know for me my my
end point was our medical tent and you
look right you look left and there's
people that are there's people that are
dead
um there's there's a there's an urgency
in the crowd of people that don't want
to leave
they want to help they want it to do
whatever they could to be an extension
of us
there were throughout the night through
in those immediate moments there were
patients being brought to us
there were bystanders that had some
clearly had some knowledge of of
medicine asking you know we need to
start CPR on this girl
when you start CPR on this this kid
um and that and that you know some of
those are images that'll never leave my
mind
um even just talking about it right now
I can I can picture two of the 58 that
lost their lives that night that died
there
um and having to look somebody in the
face asking you to do CPR on somebody
and Point Blank saying no we're not
going to do that tonight
you know it's it's easy to say that we
talk about that in a in a training
session and how we're going to manage a
mass casualty incident and what our what
our triage what our treatments going to
look like that night and it's easy to
take a test and answer those questions
but then to to be faced with
in part what is a note to me a
no-brainer right can you do CPR on this
person well I'm a you know it's what
what seemed to be such a simple question
to have to tell somebody no
um is
the right decision but it's certainly
you know something that still
in this moment just
I think it bothers me to some extent
um you know sights and sounds that
uh
uh I had never experienced in my career
or were experienced in those moments
I've run calls where people have been
shot I've run calls where multiple
people have been shot but to have
pure chaos
a patient walk up to me who had
had taken a bullet to the top of her
skull having a vivid conversation with
me trying to figure out why the top of
her head is burning
and just
just how quick those moments were but at
the same time how fast all this was
happening
yeah I mean it's
it's
hard to describe how you
I don't know if there's a way you sum up
everything that you saw that night or
everything that you experienced or
everything that you felt in in that
moment and and Beyond those immediate
minutes of of gunfire
I think
I think a lot of that is personal
you know because you go through
something or you see something or you
live something that
you can talk about it and you can tell
any reporter from The New York Times to
the Marino Gazette the story
but you're the only one in your shoes
and I think that's okay
you know
um something good
I bet came from that night for you
whether it was a moment that imprinted
whether it was a person a story a person
who made it a person who got the hug
three four weeks later
or whether it was you becoming closer
with your family and and working through
that healing process that you had to go
through where's that spot
I think there's a lot of spots
amongst this chaos to
just amongst all the chaos that was
happening that night to see people that
took objects that were never meant to be
backboards objects devices that were
never meant to move people
to see people just go to work and to
bring patients to us at
to me those are the heroes
I was assigned to be there that night
I didn't pay to go there
these people paid to go there these fans
paid to be there they paid for an
experience and
um they had like many they had the
opportunity to to evacuate and get out
of there get out of Harm's Way and they
didn't
and some didn't until you more or less
had to force them to leave
that's that's heroism
um
I think there was a bond that's that's
you know that that's been created really
amongst our community when it comes to
the EMS community
um I think there's you know moments
where
you know the people that were there that
night and the people that responded that
night
um you know there's a moment where the
first ambulance showed up
and it had been what felt like an
eternity for ambulances to show up in in
our world when resources aren't showing
up it's because the scene's not safe
and so hearing those sirens in the
distance thinking to yourself these
resources are going to be held back
and then all of a sudden that resource
shows up that ambulance shows up and
there is no hesitation from that crew
that they look you in the eye as you
make eye contact and you immediately
know that
we're working we're going to work we got
to get this done and to hear words from
fellow colleagues saying put as many as
you can back here
is that something that would happen on a
day-to-day basis
yeah I think so
um you know typically when you call
9-1-1 and ambulance responds there may
be one patient and maybe two patients
any more than that more ambulances come
and take those one or two patients but
to take as many critical patients that
this particular crew took that night
that for me was a
that was a defining moment of that night
um
I think that night for me overall and
and the days that followed
as a as a kid I always had a passion for
medicine I always wanted to to do
something medicine related I had dreams
of being a doctor of you know whatever
that looked like
um but I always thought it'd be cool to
be in an ambulance how cool would it be
to drive up and down the strip with
lights and sirens on like how cool would
that be and so straight out of high
school was given that opportunity
and over the years you know my
what I saw myself doing in medicine
shifted
um whether that was to to go to medical
school those thoughts shifted those
thoughts changed I second guessed it I
you know reconsidered it but one thing
that never changed and one thing that
for me was solidified that night
was that
I have been placed where I'm at to help
people
and that night solidified that whatever
I do in my life I want to help people
and whether that's through medicine
whether that's through you name it
I want to be there for people when it's
their moment when they're at what they
believe is the lowest of low in their
their time of need I want to be that
person and for me it's given me a drive
to explore how how do we how do we
better serve our community how do I
better serve my community
that that moment solidified that
and I'm constantly reminded of that
every time I see a sticker that says
Vegas strong
and you know unfortunately I think
things happen in our society that
various hashtags are created various
phrases are created
and growing up here in southern Nevada
there's
a lot of people don't realize that
there's Community outside of
the glitz the glamor the entertainment
the amazing stuff that our city does but
there is such a community here
it's a community that I've been
fortunate to grow up in it's a community
that I've attended College in it's a
community that I've been given the
opportunity to be able to give back in
that Vegas strong just for me as cliche
as it sounds has such a significant
meaning
for me it's an even more significant
meaning that I have an opportunity to
work at a company called community
to be able to serve my community
I I agree with you the biggest strong
hits different
it's tattooed on the back of my leg it
just
it feels different than the ones that
come and go after
yep whatever else in the days and weeks
that followed how did you guys
um take care of yourselves
yeah you know uh
believe it or not you'll meet a lot of
type a person Personalities in this
business
people that don't want help
people that are more worried about
everyone else besides themselves
and one of the things that makes me
proud to be able to work for this
organization was that from the moment
that this occurred to that morning
following the hours long that we were on
that scene
we brought in counselors we brought in a
therapists
and I can tell you that you know it's uh
EMS doesn't have it figured out First
Responders don't have it figured out
but I can tell you that this company did
everything it could
to
ensure that mental health and the
well-being of all of our employees was
taken care of
I think it's something we still struggle
with today
um it's a
you know unfortunately we still continue
to lose people to to mental health
issues in our industry
and We Know It Takes a toll on on our
Personnel
um
you know for me personally it it took a
while it took a while to crack the crack
the show for me to open up and to be
able to share
and to be able to figure out why I was
having the thoughts I was having or or
having the visions that I was having
um
but yeah there's a
it's a focus of ours it's it's something
that we deeply care about here in our
organization and you know we we
constantly try to find ways and whether
they be subtle whether they be more
direct to really focus in on the mental
health and the mental well-being of not
only our leaders but of our
men and women that every day don't know
what they're going to respond to don't
know what they're going to experience
and
truth be told don't know if they're
gonna
make it home that night
in
five years
what has changed for the better
um
you know I think there's a you know five
years later I think there's
there's a handful of things that have
changed I think from a from an industry
standpoint
there's a little bit
I think there's more emphasis to have
the uncomfortable conversations
being the entertainment capital of the
world we attract a lot we attract big
events and
When We Gather in a room with ourselves
with stakeholders and Community Partners
um
you're now in a room where we can have
those difficult conversations nobody
wants to talk about what happens if
there's a bomb what happens if there's
this device what happens if somebody
decides to do something bad and some of
them are I think easier to talk about as
opposed to others
um I think there's this underlying
I don't think I know you know in our
world in that first responder world
there's lots of conversation about
what's going to happen next
not if it's going to happen but when is
it going to happen and so I think
there's a you know there's a more
emphasis from from the industry from
from what we're doing to ensure that the
safety of all the of all those that live
here visit here and and go to these
events because
at the end of the day
Evil's not going to prevail
five years later evil has not prevailed
there's been some challenging things
that have happened in our communities
some bad things that have happened in
our community but I think five years
later
we're still
we're still this tight-knit community
we're still here to look out for one
another
we're still we're still Vegas strong
personally what's changed
um you know up until up until a week ago
it was it's
still trying to wrap my my head around
that it's been five years
it's you know it's
it's
difficult
it's you know lots of reflection you
know that night unfortunately I lost a
friend who's amongst the one of the 58
that that passed
um and and those thoughts come back
this year was the first year that
I went back through text messages that I
had from five years ago everything from
people that were checking in on me to
the text that I sent to to my family
to the text that I sent to to somebody
that died
and that was the first time in in the
five years I'm sure I looked at him you
know post post the event but probably
the first time that kind of stirred
these emotions that
you know
in those
I think we have a tendency to
compartmentalize where we put feelings
and where our emotions are stored and
for me five years later it it kind of
it's opened up
some of those
but for me it again it reminds me of the
community that I'm a part of it reminds
me of the opportunity I have to be able
to do what I do to be able to sit down
and be able to share
my story to be able to share the story
of the hundreds and thousands of people
in our community that helped that night
for those that are complete strangers to
our community that every year they come
back
and want to
they're a part of this unique Community
that's that's been created after such a
horrific event
anything
I mean we can obviously talk about
the role the public played in helping
you their ingenuity
their willingness to stand there beside
you
I mean how cool would it be if
it's a community to come together again
make sure you know your CPR trained to
make sure your kids know how to swim
make sure you're donating blood we could
talk about
all of those things that just as being a
good Community person are important
but I think I can kind of write to some
of that sure I just want to make sure
that you're feeling okay about it and
that you're saying everything
that you want to say if there's anything
that stood out or
yeah no you know I think you know when
it comes to
our communities stood up for the
the minutes and the hours and the days
and the weeks and the years since that
event there was a
there was a it was a it was a different
and it still is
um there was almost a turn
you know for for somebody you know
walking into a Starbucks in uniform
somebody holding the door open for you
and just saying thank you
um you know it's
it's uh it's easy for me to thank people
um but when people were thinking me it
was
maybe to this day it's hard you know and
I I don't I don't stand behind the
um what's what you're paid to do it's
it's what you signed up for
nobody that wears our uniform signed up
for that night nobody that wears our
uniform signs up to get shot at nobody
signs up for this career to to deal with
demons and have nightmares is it a part
of the job it's become part of the job
but
um yeah the community just really showed
up that night and you know it's I think
it's just important that
we have these difficult conversations
you know stop the bleed training where
we teach people how to put tourniquets
on and
how you can
truly save somebody's life those are
tools that came out of bad experiences
you know we learn a lot of this stuff
because of war and that's a tool that
you know we use in EMS and it was a tool
that that night was an important tool
and you know a very Vivid thought that
night was seeing folks that would take
blankets that would take stethoscopes
that were taking seat belts and turning
them into tourniquets because it's such
an important tool and uh yeah I mean I
you know our
I truly believe that we're all placed
where we are for a reason we have bad
things that happen in life we have a few
bad sour apples in our in our society
but we're a community that is here to
look out for one another and support one
another and anything we can do to to
make ourselves better in turn makes our
community that much stronger
I don't believe so
uh